the world of automobiles has changed in
the last 10 years this is partly due to
Tesla's daring approach to vehicles and
the rise of their successful electric
vehicles in the last few years new
markets have emerged for electric
vehicles and experimental automobile
companies new automobile Giants have
tried to create the lightning that Tesla
hit unfortunately many companies have
promised to deliver however time has
judged them as Pretenders with nothing
or little to show for all their promises
not even Tesla is immune from this a
glaring example of its failed promise is
the Cyber truck however one company
looks like it has a real shot of being
more than a pretender one company that
stands out with real promise canoe canoe
is an EV startup that is on a mission to
bring EVS to everyone today we will be
discussing its EV truck simply called
the canoe pickup truck and why it's
genius exterior Design After Decades of
dominance it appears that the Twilight
of the internal combustion engine in the
automobile industry might finally be
upon us since the 1910s the internal
combustion engine has shaped the
automobile industry as the dominant fuel
source this means that most cars were
designed to suit combustion engines
however the quick rise of EVS has
brought a breath of fresh air to the
automobile industry designers in the
industry now have a fresh canvas to
create something new in spite of this
opportunity to spice things up some
heavyweight players in the industry like
Ford have chosen to stick to a safe
design that brought them success a quick
comparison between the original Ford
F-150 and the Ford F-150 reveals very
few obvious design changes design wise
the trunk just serves as an extra
storage space the canoe pickup truck
explores the more exciting path of
creating a fresh product canoe was
designed from scratch with the aim of
creating only the most efficient truck
every detail of the truck is essential
and adds value other than following the
conventional design Playbook the canoe
truck tears up the Playbook creating a
truck that is built for the future this
is hardly a surprise after all canoe is
among the automobile firms that are
pushing the design boundaries of future
Vehicles however in an interesting twist
the exterior design of the canoe pickup
truck Bears similarities with the past a
quick trip to 1960 would have a familiar
car the forward control vehicle forward
control trucks were a trend that had
cars like the Jeep forward control
achieve success although canoe shares
some similarities with the forward
control vehicles both vehicles could not
be more different for one unlike the
forward control vehicles that still had
to rely on a combustion engine the canoe
pickup truck has no engine this means
that the forward control although
through Ingenuity tried to create space
for a forward control engine it had to
place the combustion engine under the
cabin the canoe pickup truck is easily
able to navigate some of the challenges
of the old forward troll vehicle because
it likes an engine the absence of the
engine offers a better cabin experience
the exterior design looks masculine the
pickup truck features a horizontal hood
that connects to a curved windshield
from the truck's front end to the roof
this design appears very futuristic in
line with the canoe fashion the
headlight was also designed with poise
the headlights appear in a t-shaped
fashion that provides a unique light
signature the body of the EV is a
unibody design without any gap between
the extended cab and the six foot bed
the overall exterior design of the canoe
pickup truck explores New Frontiers for
an electric truck interior design like
the exterior design the canoe pickup
truck stands out in the automobile
industry canoe's pickup truck interior
design is genius and definitely ahead of
its peers leveraging on the absence of
an internal combustion engine up front
the canoe began designing their vehicle
from scratch the objective was to create
a multi-purpose pickup truck the
interior of the truck looks minimalist
right off the bat it gives an air of
containing only the essential items
without a combustion engine the EV truck
designers were able to manage the extra
space they got the cabin seats are moved
further to the truck the cabin seats
appear just behind the car axle
maximizing the space in the vehicle
there is an option of two additional
seats behind the cabin a common theme in
the canoe truck is customizable features
the additional seats are modular
although the rectangularly shaped
steering wheel initially seems like a
strange choice for such an efficient car
the canoe truck has earned such leeway
with its other good work a bonus is that
the rectangular steering wheel adds to
the Ultra Modern aesthetic of the truck
the driver's seat and passenger seat are
nicely tucked inboard from the doors it
eliminates the need for the center
console and brings people closer like
other EVS there are only a few buttons
that remain in the console panel in the
car there is a long curved windshield
that wraps around the roof the
appearance of the interior of the truck
expels a Chic atmosphere canoe is yet to
announce particular modularity features
however the truck will likely feature
standard and optional features that you
can select depending on your specific
tasks storage another strength of the
canoe pickup truck is its storage
features the canoe truck comes equipped
with some never seen before storage
features for instance the pickup truck
bed is six feet long and four feet wide
you could use the truck to transport
bikes on the bed it has enough room
impressively the truck comes with an
additional layer of bed underneath the
truck that provides an option of an
extra two feet that would accommodate
four by eight feet of plywood the
pullover bed extension also helps with
loading and unloading the truck this
truck also offers storage space at both
sides of the truck this side storage
makes for a flexible storage area for
objects such as a first aid kit and a
cooler for Refreshments it also has a
lockable laptop storage a again on Space
the truck offers a front cargo storage
area where the engine of a typical car
would be the area can hold on to work
tools or gym equipment depending on the
needs of the owner this impressive
storage feature of the canoe truck is
only possible because of its insanely
structured design finally the roof rack
exists on top of the truck that can
store any additional items Swiss Army
truck the canoe pickup truck was made
with different use cases in mind the
design of the truck is very flexible
towards the different needs of different
classes of customers Tony Aquila the
company CEO stated our pickup truck is
as strong as the toughest trucks out
there and is designed to be
exponentially more productive this truck
works for you we made accessories for
people who use trucks on the job
weekends Adventures you name it the
truck bed comes with modular dividers
that can help break up the bed into
smaller units of space this could mean
creating as many as three different
pockets of space that will not interfere
with each other you can have a toolbox a
plant and extra room for a third item
group the truck could also provide
workspaces for people the truck bed can
be flipped over as tables that can be
handy for job site workers on both sides
of the truck you can find site storage
that can be used as workspaces too right
in front of the truck where there would
ordinarily be an engine there is a
foldable bench that is yet another
workspace these workplaces are usually
close to the multiple power outlets in
the truck this means that the truck has
some features for job site usage
anticipating that sometimes there might
be need for light around the truck bed
canoe's pickup truck is also equipped
with lamps around the truck bed and in
the frontal stage area of the truck
canoe has also suggested that the truck
will come in different options there is
an optional camper shell that might
appeal to campers Travelers and other
people with such needs the optional
camper shell connects over the truck bed
another option is the extended roof rack
option which is made possible with the
optional campus shells it could even
come with rooftop tents size the overall
length of the truck is 184 inches 213
inches with the bed extension at 78
inches wide and 76 inches tall the roof
rack is 48 by 54 inches the bed depth is
21 inches where the bed is 64 by 72
inches the design efficiency of the
truck allows the truck to have a smaller
frame than other trucks with its smaller
frame the canoe pickup truck can offer
cargo storable space that larger trucks
could fail to offer this creates an edge
for the canoe truck because pickup
trucks typically struggle in some
terrains parking in particular and
driving in countries with narrow roads
can be difficult for pickup truck lovers
essentially you can get the in-vehicle
space of a larger pickup truck without
struggling in urban terrains as a
regular pickup truck performance
although canoe has not officially
confirmed the specific performance
figures of the canoe pickup truck it has
stated that it would be above 5 500
horsepower the truck comes in two
versions rear-wheel drive or rwd or
all-wheel drive AWD the major difference
is that all-wheel drive is better at
retaining controls of the vehicle under
various situations rear wheel drive is
expected at 300 horsepower and all-wheel
drive is expected at 500 horsepower
canoe reports its all-wheel drive truck
has a payload capacity of 1 800 pounds
since the single motor van is packed at
6.3 seconds from 0 to 60 miles an hour
the dual motor pickup truck should be
able to produce faster results the canoe
also reports its battery capacity has a
200 plus mile range from a single charge
pricing having noted one of the biggest
barriers to EV canoe has priced its
Vehicles sensibly it is impressive how
many useful features canoe has been able
to cram into their EV truck all the
while keeping the price affordable last
year's bargain the Ford F-150 Lightning
that starts at 53 000 for the most basic
option and goes as high as 98 000. other
EV trucks cost a significant sum the
rivian r1t starts at seventy thousand
dollars the GMC hummery vsut starts at
87 000 and the Lordstown endurance
starts at 65 000 although there is yet
to be announced an official price for
the canoe pickup truck it is expected
that the starting price will be about
thirty five thousand dollars coming in
at that price the canoe pickup truck
would be a bargain the canoe pickup
would enter a unique space in the
American Market offering an
environmentally friendly affordable and
flexible vehicle canoe would enter an
untapped Market with lots of
opportunities it can undercut the
premium EV trucks such as the Ford F-150
Lightning pickup the Chevrolet Silverado
EV work truck and other EV trucks it can
also thrive in the compact pickup Market
against Vehicles like the Ford Ranger
Chevrolet Colorado and Toyota Tacoma the
canoe pickup truck will likely also
compete in the Overland vehicles base
the features such as the rooftop place
it as a contender with other Overland
Vehicles potentially the canoe pickup
can replace Toyota 4Runners and Jeep
Wranglers this is one of the greatest
strengths of the canoe pickup truck it
has been designed and positioned to
operate in different car markets powered
by electricity it appeals to EV
enthusiasts and green supporters its
ergonomics appeal to those looking for a
compact pickup and it is suitable for
Interstate traveling for a small group
The Future the automobile industry is an
industry that only a few can enter the
more established companies have an edge
in almost everything an intending
entrant to the industry such as canoe
will need to rely on novelty creativity
and even genius to break into the market
canoe has faced numerous challenges
ranging from labor shortages supply
chain disruptions and the tightening
financial markets at its first quarter
Financial press conference this
statement was made due to the timing of
our announced funding and the 2014 fasb
accounting rule as of the date of this
announcement we are reporting that there
is substantial doubt about the company's
ability to continue as a going concern
however canoe had a much better 2022
with an agreement to supply Walmart with
four and a half thousand of its EV van
it also announced that it had submitted
an altered version of its pickup truck
for testing by the US Army this might
just serve as a Lifeline for the company
the jury is out if canoe can survive the
industry however the jury is in on the
unique and exciting canoe pickup truck
it also remains to be seen when and if
the canoe truck will ever arrive at the
store it also remains to be seen if the
market advantage that the canoe truck
has now will be available when the canoe
pickup truck is ever able to be released
if you believe in the canoe pickup truck
and what they are doing you can
subscribe with a refundable 100 deposit
if you enjoyed this video check out our
other awesome videos on the channel
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time